زرقه السماء وسفره سنابل القمح في العلم
الاوكراني ليست مجرد تفسير شعبي لرمز دوله
فحسب بل ثروه استراتيجيه وترجمه لاحد اهم
السلال الغذاء في العالم فماذا لو كانت
هذه السله مهدده
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ليست مجرده صراع
بين دولتين متجاورتين بل حرب بين قطبين
لانتاج وتصدير الغذاء في العالم عرضت خلال
امدادات الغذائي للخطر فروسيا الاولى
دوليا في صادرات القمح واوكرانيا الخامسه
عالميا لكن الحرب عرضت الاسواق لمزيد من
الصدمات والتقلبات التي لحقت بها نتيجه
جائحه كورونا
شهر واحد بعد الحرب جعل الاسعار تقفز الى
مستوى هو الاعلى على الاطلاق بمعدل بالغاء
نحو 34% وفق ارقام منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه
العالميه عاد عن بقاء ملايين الاطنان
عالقه في الموانئ
بجهود تركيه ورعايه امميه اتفاق اسطنبول
اعاد بارقه الامل
ولا ان استانفت صادرات الحبوب في اواخر
يوليو بعد الاتفاق الا ان التداعيات كانت
عميقه وخصوصا على الشرق الاوسط حيث تؤكد
منظمات دوليه ان الحرب فاقمت الجوع واثرت
على سلاسل امدادات الغذاء الى الشرق
الاوسط وادت لنقص في المواد الاساسيه ومن
بين اكثر الدول تضررا لبنان ومصر التي تعد
اكبر مستورد للقمح في العالم عدا عن سوريا
واليمن وبعد حول كامل من الحرب تتعزز
المخاوف بشان مستقبل الامن الغذائي
العالمي خشيه توسع الحرب جغرافيا او نوعيا
وتشتد التطلعات لوقفها باقل فاتوره ممكنه
ليس فقط سياسيا وامنيا وانما اقتصاديا
وغذائيا